hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from the Nations Cup
and well my phone's been ringing nonstop
with hashtag suggestions of this game
and for good reasons it's unlike
anything I've seen in a very long time
I'm not gonna say ever but in a very
long time especially between two such
strong players one is a formal role
chess champion and the other one is the
current well member of the candidates
tournament that is currently being
adjourned but obviously the players are
of the highest caliber so such a game
really really just best for me to just
show it but your friends at the bar in
the library are really going to enjoy
this one so Anand with the white pieces
opens with d4 with nitro six pineapple
c4 and g6 nipper will go for his groom
full defense he much like maxim enjoys
the night or food with against e4 and
the groom fell against d4 so see
characters on d5 we have night cap
person d5 and now on and it doesn't go
for the immediate e4 which is not the
most popular move here but rather
prepares it with Bishop to d2 saying
that okay after I kick your night away
would be for I'm just gonna recapture on
c3 with the bishop so it's gonna be a
bit different than than the standard
neither grew filled with Bishop to g7 by
neppo and now II for now just kicking
away that night Knight captures and c3
with Bishop captures and c3 and now c5
and the difference between recapturing
with the b-pawn rather than playing
first Bishop to b2 is that now you can
play d5 otherwise you just have Bishop
captures so with Czech you're gonna grab
the be the the c3 pawn and the White
will lose the rook so here it is
possible to grab a bit more space in the
center with d5 with bushel captures and
c3 by neppo B captures on c3 and now
just Queen to b6 developing the Queen
preventing the immediate e5 and the next
black will castle develop deny the world
the light square Bishop and so on so
here on unplaced Queen d2 now he now
wants to play f4 and continue with his
pushing in the center with E 5 so nipple
castles and now f4 as planned so I'm
really doing a lot here in the center
with his King still being in the same
with ecigs pineapple and now this exact
same position has been reached already
in this year's candidate tournament
between onigiri and Maxim Varsha
holograph
in this position Giri went for Bishop to
c4 and that game ended in a draw however
here Anand prepares Knight to f3 and it
is a new move in the position so already
as a move 12 we have a completely new
game nipa continues with he captures and
b5 of course he wants to open up the
position as Anand King is still in the
center of the board and only now uh none
goes Bishop to c4 now you cannot capture
as the Queen would hang here and also he
just prepares at the castle
so Knepper just goes to Bishop to e6
adds another defender to the d5 pawn and
Anand just castles here and here
nipple deciding what to do he pushes d4
which allows for some nice trade you
think you can trade here you can trade
here which would give also nipple the
semi-open F file so a lot of things you
could do here however nipple yeah I did
not realize but by pushing d4 he is now
completely lost and Anand now has a way
of winning the game on the spot so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this winning move while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
as it's not an easy move to find the
engine struggles with it and only at you
know higher depths with will the engine
acknowledge that this is actually
winning for white but for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show its f5
and here you can easily resign the game
point is that it doesn't matter how
black replies White's next series of
moves is the same it doesn't matter if
you move the bishop doesn't matter if
you capture the bishop so obviously
those are the two options you remove the
bishop otherwise you're gonna be down a
piece or you capture the bishop so here
nipple captured the bishop but now comes
the idea Anand had a five and now
Nepos queen is under attack so obviously
have to do something about that you
cannot capture as the night.the defends
it so nipple play the Queen to d7 but it
doesn't really matter where we move the
Queen because Anand next move is the
same and here on unplayed f6 and it was
in this position on move 17 that Janna
pony she resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here Allen's next moves will be
Queen to h6 followed by Queen to g7 mate
and there is nothing you can do to
prevent this whatever you play now even
though you're a piece doesn't really
matter there's no way for you to give
back material you can even grab more
material still just Queen h6 fall by
Queen g7 mate and there's no way to
defend any move you make it's just just
a beautiful position and one definitely
still be remembered such a miniature in
modern times against the groom felt
really you know this might this might
really make this Bishop 2d to line a bit
more popular as players with the white
pieces will will maybe try to emulate
this in blitz and maybe bullet games so
really really wild stuff hard to imagine
that this is a game that was played in
an actual online tournament between such
strong modern players in 2020 you know
it would be more likely it's a game from
from the morphe era and well III don't
know I'm pretty sure it's it's a
prepared variation from home but I will
still award Anand with the morphe head
there we go for such a wonderful victory
ah now that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and I do hope your friends at
the bar in the library will also enjoy
it I would like to thank Russell Lloyd
Philip saw it now Daniel Vasquez
Alexander galitsky and andreas Rosenthal
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see soon continuing the coverage of
the Nations Cup and whatever I would
ever say and manage in this time so now
I think y'all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day